les images difficiles à supporter mais
qu'on devrait vivre moins souvent quand
la fréquentation du métro sera revenu à
la normale
les heures de pointe seront plus faciles
grâce à ça sous cet immense cratère à la
station côte vertu
le nouveau garage pour les métro de la
stm va permettre d'ajouter dix trains
sur la ligne orange et d'augmenter la
fréquence qui est au mieux de deux
minutes 35 en ce moment avec le garage
puis l'ajout des traits on veut diminuer
c'est cet intervalle entre les traits
loupé avec la carte et rincon et l'on
pourrait aller jusqu'à 2009 les travaux
commencés en 2017 sont presque terminés
malgré la résiliation d'un contrat
majeur l'automne dernier pour le béton
un kilomètre et demi de tunnels ont été
creusés à 30 mètres de profondeur pour
garer et réparer les trains
l'objectif de ce garage l'eau ça nous
permet d'augmenter l'offre de service
puis ça permet s'est associé aussi à la
ligne bleue
car la sdn anticipe une hausse
d'achalandage avec le prolongement du
métro et elle voit aussi plus loin en
surface à québec la décision n'a
toujours pas été prise de prolonger la
ligne orange jusqu'à la station
bois-francs dur m
mais en sous sol l'asm prépare déjà le
terrain elle a commencé à creuser deux
tunnels pour accueillir davantage de
trains le budget a été dépassé d'environ
70 millions de dollars pour atteindre
492 millions financés par québec et
ottawa les impacts de la fin des travaux
pour les usagers ne seront pas nu la
station côte-vertu sera fermée du 29 mai
au 22 août pour intégrer un aiguillage
car elles navaient pts à haute fréquence
qui fera le service entre la station
côte vertu et la station du collège en
or de points que leurs et varie entre
une minute aux cinq mines
malgré les problèmes de contrats de co
vide de matériaux la stm pense pouvoir
respecter son échéancier et mettre en
service dix trains supplémentaires à
l'heure de pointe dès le printemps 2022
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal